قت
هيك هنا وبداخل مدارس الاونر والتابعه
للامم المتحده لجا عشرات الالاف من
الفلسطينيين الى مدينه دير البلا حيث تاوي
هذه المدارس اعداد كبيره من النازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين جاؤوا من مدينه غزه ومن
شمال القطاع خلال الايام الاولى للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه الفلسطينيين هنا
يتحدثون عن اوضاع انسانيه صعبه للغايه
يقضونها داخل الفصول الدراسيه
والله احنا حالتنا صعبه وضعنا
صعب اودي كلهم في جباليه واحنا اولادك انت
وبنتي وبنتي كنا هان مرميين لا اكل ولا
شرب ولا حاجه الوضع صعب صعب ف تصور انت
تفرجت على المدرسه كيف شكلها انا بنتي بد
جوز وصغر عينين انا عيانه من يوم ما جيت
ابن بنتي مات مات من المرض
مات
مريض عنده اسما في المشكله مات امبارح
مات هنا حتى المساعدات الانسانيه التي تصل
لهؤلاء النازحين في مدارس الاونر بالكد
تفي الاحتياجات اليوميه لهم حسب ما
يتحدثون ويقولوا بان في الاسبوع مرتين يتم
اعطائهم بعض من المعلبات والمستلزمات التي
تقدمها الانر ولهؤلاء النز الذين هم
متواجدين منذ ايام طويله في هذه المدارس
شوف كيف ميه وحبه عدس عايشين على ميه وحبه
عدسه هذا اللي عايشين
[موسيقى]
عليه عشت الذل وعشت المهانه وعيش الوساخه
ما فيش نظافه وساخه ما فيش نظافه من مره
اولادنا بيحبوا على الزباله وع الدوده
اللي بيطلع من الزباله ش بدي نحكي لكم لا
اكل في في نظافه ولا شرب نظافه هي قاعدين
لا في حريمات ولا في فرشات ولا في اي حاجه
لنا ويعطونا قطعه فرشه ننام عليها خمس
انفار ست نفار رفح هيكه عان ننام
عليه والتخوفات الكبيره هنا مدارس
الاونروا في دير البلح من وقف المساعدات
الانسانيه التي تقدمها الاونروا بعد توقف
عدد من دول العالم عن تقديم المساعدات
لهذه المؤسسه الدوليه اشرف ابو عمره لقناه
الجزيره دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه